oh yeah public broadcasting well public
broadcasting is an interesting case in a
lot of countries public broadcasting is
10 I mean how free public broadcasting
is public broadcasting is not subject as
much at least to business and to
corporate and advertiser pressures
however of course it's subject to state
pressures and how free and independent
public broadcasting is depends typically
on how free the state is not like in a
free society public broadcasting will be
free for many years the BBC was very
independent with sure another
anti-democratic reactionary the BBC has
been become much more constrained
because the British government is also
imposing harsh constraints on freedom of
expression under Thatcher another's
mislabeled conservative but turning to
the United States public broadcasting is
very weak as compared with virtually any
other country any other democratic
country you know any of the you look at
the industrial democratic societies they
all have public broadcasting some of
them are only public broadcasting for
example in Israel is only a state TV in
England until recently there was only
state TV and now there's another channel
2 other channels i think in canada if I
till recently there's only CBC there may
be another one now I forgotten but
that's common I mean those are major
channels and that's true of most
countries and how free they are depends
on how for either country is in the
United States they're very weak because
here things are run by corporations this
is a business run society and things
supposed to be under corporate control
so public broadcasting is very limited
and in fact it survives to a large
extent on corporate donations which is a
constraint Gulf and Western and one
famous case forced wnet TV in New York
to cancel a program on hunger simply by
saying they remove their Seban shin and
they submit and public broadcasting is
is you know it varies across the country
in the major centers like Boston
Washington and New York it's very very
narrow it's in fact it's I think it's
more tightly censored in corporate
radeon television in other parts of the
country like you know Laramie Wyoming
and the y in Iowa may be here it's more
free and that makes sense the same is
true of the commercial media because in
the ideological centers it's much more
important to control what people think
what they think out in the sticks
doesn't matter so much because there's
not much they can do about it and as a
result the it's more open I mean I can
see that myself if i go to Laramie I get
interviewed on public television on
public television but that same
conceiver chua lee inconceivable and go
awesome you know maybe minute now and
then or something in the interests of
you know fairness or something but that
and big and the reason is that you know
for the main centers like say Boston are
subject to what's called the liberal
bias meaning tightly controlled by
ideological managers who know their
business and don't let things get out of
hand I think it's possible to put the
kind of pressures on public broadcasting
that can't be done on corporate media
but to that that requires organization
and real participation there are other
forms i should say one of the most some
of the most interesting and important
things are listener supported radio now
that's usually a small-scale operation
you know fly-by-night operation but
they're very important that's really out
of corporate control or state control
and you can tell you travel around as i
do to communities and the ones that have
listener supported radio are quite
different there's just an independent
culture that can sustain itself there
with people participating and you know
involvement of the community i mean it's
just much more democratic and that you
can see the results but that's you know
very limited resources because resources
lie essentially in the business
community